boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun we
are still at the raw Science Film
Festival the fifth annual propagating
epicness in media about science and
inspiring the next generation of
creators we are now with soos a green
thank you said it thank you so much this
year it's really excited to talk all
things songwriting all things American
singer songwriter of The Supremes
a steam advocate activist super pumped
to talk about all this everything yes
yeah exactly exactly and just the soul
that came through you into me when you
were singing on stage was very profound
it just rang through me
laughs I had to stand up and dance
that's the good result mmm and just to
give you an idea of who she is the songs
unconditional love yeah Cyndi so be out
in just a few days yeah sold everywhere
yeah yes well we need to awaken to the
unconditional yes we did we do so let's
let's jump into that specifically so we
find ourselves here after a long period
of evolution we like taking a big
history perspective on things so now
we're stewards of Earth after this long
period of time we have exponential
technology happening all this population
of people but the heart the heart
centric are we educating kids in that
realm of thinking what's your synthesis
on the current state of humanity
we are hopeful because there is a very
large group of conscientious people who
believe that there is hope for us as a
what shall we say as a race of human
beings you know and we have the
opportunity because of the technology
because of the knowledge to do anything
great anything fine and we don't a lot
of times because people are fooled I
think by Fame you know they want they
want Fame so many young people want to
be famous but if you ask them for what
they don't necessarily have a particular
talent they have the passion and the
determination to do something great but
they're not preparing you know when I
was going to school you you took music
classes and you you took art history and
and you know you you prepared if you
were going to be a musician and this is
what I always tell young people if
you're going to be a musician you need
to prepare you need to take some music
classes you need to learn how to read
music and if you're a singer you need to
nurture that talent you know I I was
very blessed in that my own mother was a
vocal coach she was a tremendous
classical pianist she was deadly serious
about it you you did what you had to do
and she was my first coach she taught me
to love music and my mother and father
were some of the first black DJs in
America so it made for a wonderful music
education seriously my my father was
into jazz so I learned all kinds of
things like Illinois Jacquet and Willie
the lion Smith
you know we miles and all these people
who really believed that music was a
healer that's quite a thing right there
and that's what's missing right now mmm
you know I talked to Mickey Stevenson
who was the first ANR man at at Motown
and he's the one who put the funk
brothers together the group that
supported all the acts that played on
all those hit records and the thing that
he said was hit and who is it a sacred
it is the sounds make you feel yes like
you said your soul you feel something in
your soul well there's a lot of music
that I like nowadays but there's also a
music a lot of music that is not melodic
you know to have one or two chords no
chord changes at all and the rap
community the hip-hop community has been
very kind to me because two particular
songs one was free that was Denise
Williams first million-seller as I just
got to and you know it is a cultural
icons type of song and rappers have
embraced it have loved it and have
sampled it and the same with I can't
help it which I wrote with Stevie Wonder
on Michael Jackson's off-the-wall album
and that album changed pop music because
it had such a broad spectrum of dance
ability great lyrics great melodies and
the particular song that particular song
and Stevie had written for himself four
songs in the key of life
and his sister who grew up with Michael
and all his family said you shouldn't
Michaels Cigna and you know he kind of
know this is a great song
it's hard to let a great song go
sometimes but he was right to let
Michael do it you know and and it was
the one song on that album that was sort
of Michael's most sophisticated
presentation as an adult as a young
adult
but music and I think the power of music
is in the feeling is that we translate
that to other people we go all around
the world we travel and people don't
speak the same language but come on we
we all feel we all fall in love we all
want wish desire you know it's a
commonality that we share and that's
very important to me there's a couple
things I want to address here the first
thing is that and we're going to get
into your path and music here you
started hinting at it and I just started
getting really delicious and exciting
yeah I like it I like it not only did
you tie in music and how you prepared
yeah you're with your family as well as
mom and dad but how a lot of us now are
born and not necessarily preparing how
many of the seven point seven billion I
have I have identified the ones that are
old enough have identified with their
mission in life with their purpose is on
this planet not only that but then are
they making the short-term steps that
they need to do every day in order to
actualize that mission that's an
interesting thought and we need to get
to a society that pushes that paradigm
more and more and more can in and when
that when a child is born we're able to
help them identify what that mission is
that and then give and help give them
the right tools that they need to to get
and and then that's a whole perspective
shift on oh you you I oh we want we want
Fame or we want money or we want
materialistic objects know you want
something important is impact I want to
bring value to the world I'm gonna I
want to inspire the rest of the world to
have an awareness shift all that stuff
I loved how you brought that there so
now let's let's talk let's talk music
and related to you started teaching us
about you know mom was saying it yeah
and that's huge that's already hugely
influential all right and even in in
epigenetics coded in the body infantry
and then the father and mother Oh both
deejaying as well so so tell us about
how you started picking it up and then
because I love how you say it so it's
about that that that that translational
yeah Phoenix too you know and I was a
very little girl I was so like always
saying I would be humming something I
wrote my first song at eight years old
you know but music had a special place
in my heart
because I've always known that it was a
part of me you know I sang I wrote songs
I created and that's the thing right
there is the creation of things creators
writers and it develops you know the
things that you do the things that you
think the things that you think are what
you become but the main thing aside from
music that my mother taught me was that
nothing is impossible come on nothing
you know she was the youngest person to
ever graduate from Prairie View college
she was 17
there's a brilliant woman when she
graduated from college she was so young
at college she had to have a chaperone
can you imagine that
party pooper but she was a serious
student she had been nurtured her talent
was nurtured she played Mozart at 3:00
she was a child prodigy and because she
was surrounded by people who knew that
she had tremendous talent and she was a
natural teacher she instilled that in us
she told me that as a woman as a black
woman as a short person as a so many
things you can be maligned or put down
and yet you can do anything that you
decide to do because other people's
opinions of you you know everybody loves
a winner see so if you have that focus
and that's the main difference I believe
focus between young people who don't do
something don't have a drive or a desire
and people who create and make something
make a legacy make a difference is focus
determination you know you have to know
I've always known what I was gonna do
and yet I know people who still at 50 60
they don't know what they want to do in
life and we all search for that see
that's the thing we search and I think
you know if you have an inkling excuse
me I believe you have to be passionate
there has to be something and it doesn't
matter what your passion is if you're
passionate about orchids then you should
be doing something with orchids for your
life but what we do is we think okay
p-diddy you know it's all about the
money
more money more problems the beat all
these things the clothing the lights
it's all attractive to people and not
just young people but it's a false thing
you know if you have something that you
are passionate about it's not about how
much money you can make in life you can
be happy with less but I think somebody
has to tell you that you know I really
do I have I've been very blessed I have
I've had opportunities to see things to
travel to do things sing places that
other people have never been and may not
but many people are inspired by the fact
that I'm humble that
no I'm talented if I weren't confident
in what I do I wouldn't be able to do it
when you have five reign you know a
range of five octaves you have to be
confident to hit those notes it's
controlled you know that's five octave
range yes absolutely yeah you know and
it depends on the day it can be more you
know but they're not those only the dogs
can hear right that's more than a stream
like a violin or viola cello does that's
four off years but it's natural you
understand I believe you know it's you
can learn but a natural talent
I can sing hi
when I struggle to sing low sometimes
depending upon how I feel it's my
natural range you know so the confidence
yeah the fact that my mother told me
that I was loved and I believed her that
you can do anything that you try if you
put your heart and soul into it if you
are focused as well limit yeah those
were so good right there that was so
good
the again that second that that's such
an important part yet unconditional love
from mother the you can do anything set
your mind to you retain focus I'm
interested if you could have done what
you did if you were addicted to social
media because it didn't exist back then
but that's what that's a big very true
city it's a big distraction but social
media doesn't distract me many many
classic artists who have been big stars
who have done great things are afraid to
deal with social media because it's
intimidating to them you know but I
looked at this thing the information
highway it's such a good one more kids
need to be right there
right next to them formation a milk King
taught us that yeah yeah well I heard it
in the middle of the night and it was
Steve Jobs talking about the information
and I like perked up because I'm look
I'm a woman who has always loved
intelligence and intellect and tools you
know it's a tool for if you have contact
with the world if you have talent your
people will find you online and if you
think about the places we go Twitter
Facebook Instagram LinkedIn they're free
oh my goodness they may not always be
free now hopefully their business plans
change
yes exactly I'd rather gladly pay 20
bucks a month for those than has
attention economy trying reeling in
there's so much better we can do with
actually that data that we could
actually own and make much better use of
it well I agree oh you're a wealth of
wisdom because we could we could easily
just go off and spin into tons of
conversational topics right now but I
want people to know about what is it
like being a part of The Supremes like
what what is it like to have because you
know when we were talking about behind
the groove as well Sydney what's
interesting is that most most most
people when they eat at a restaurant
they don't see the chef and the and the
bussers and the waiters waitresses and
in the menu decisions and the food
ordering right same thing with the music
a song you don't see the 12 people that
are involved you only see the person's
scene that's right at the end result yes
so to just about the complexity of all
well my my the thing is I learned and I
will back up just a little bit I sang
with Ray Charles for a long time my job
was to do a solo him playing the piano
and some of that's online who can find
it and I was trusted we understand I was
19 18 and 19 when I began with Ray and
he trusted me because I could sing what
I was told to sing I had a very quick
memory I could learn something just you
know before you go onstage I could read
if it comes down to that you could do it
now and do it that way and you you can
be depended on you know an 18-piece ban
you're dealing with the big boys you
know and if he's a scared
let's get you know I could handle it but
the thing that I learned
from him every single night he'd sing I
can't stop loving you with the same
depth of feeling the same passion burn
it down and he used to say I would sing
for free but don't tell anybody until
I'm gone do you know
I would sing for free because he knew I
understood that I could look that in the
face and this is what I do and I'll do
it to my best ability every single time
because that's what it's about it's
about those people who come out of
themselves they come they're going out
and they need elevating they need
inspiring they need uplifting they need
something a little bit out of the
ordinary and have you ever considered
when you're on stage you're up a little
higher you see so people are looking up
at you and they need to admire what they
see when they get up there I began with
The Supremes after Ray I sang with
Stevie Wonder we did a lot of writing
and we were like big teenagers you know
24/7 weeks show up at the studio in the
middle of the night and do whatever we
were doing you know and we recorded
songs in the key of life and other
things but totally different and it
believe me it doesn't escape me that I
worked with the two premiere blind
singers in the world musicians in the
world but they each taught me and in a
different thing
Stevie taught me how to really write a
song how to write it and then rewrite it
but when I it came time for The Supremes
you know and it's all about timing it's
all about that my mother once again was
on the Executive Board of the end of
lace EP in Beverly Hills and
she was friends with Bob Jones Bob Jones
was the head of publicity at Motown and
he told her that Cindy birdsong was
leaving and would I be interested she
called me and said how would you like to
be a supreme okay and I thought well
haven't done that before but that sounds
interesting because as a teenager you
know I grew up in New York and we saw
those three little girls from Detroit we
saw them come along we saw the one with
the big eyes we saw the long to little
heart shaped face for the other one
whose left chest looked like a Barbie
doll
you know there was something for
everyone in The Supremes that was the
key so she said would you like to do
that and I said yes and they sent a
limousine a what was it a big Mercedes
limousine long white car with
blacked-out windows that had belonged to
George Harrison the Beagle and they came
to pick me up from wonder loved
rehearsal and I didn't tell anyone I was
leaving wonder loving her so I just got
in that car and went on you know and
they're still friends we are still
friends wonder love Nate watts is still
with Stevie Wonder Shirley brewer Denise
Williams I spoke to just the other night
you know because free has been recorded
a game it's gonna be someone Norman
Brown's first single off of his album
and that's songwriting good song as song
as the song as a song goes on forever so
I went into the Supremes and Jerry Payne
Mary Wilson were so gracious to me
and I knew it was difficult because
Cindy was their friend you know as she
was leaving to do other things it was an
opportunity to see firsthand
real pros real pros and I've always been
in a professional setting but this was
on a different level the glamour or the
clothing the big hair textures you know
he loved it yeah right but the thing
that impressed me more than anything is
you would see the same people around the
world thank you
how are you here we just saw you in New
York and here we are in Switzerland
save my money okay I save my money so I
can get on a plane and go and support
you well that's a legacy you see it's a
legacy I say in the show when three
little girls went to Detroit in Detroit
went to see mr. Barry Gordy they were
Mary Wilson Florence Ballard and Diana
Ross then Cindy birdsong came in the
group and they became Diana Ross and The
Supremes then Jean Terrell replaced
Diana Ross a whole bunch of other hits
then Lynda Lawrence came in the group
sherry Payne and myself the last supreme
you know but the thing about The
Supremes is and I found it difficult
from time to time once I left the group
because people expect you to be a
supreme and I'm just to say
but that's part that's a great part of
what I do and what I love and I love the
glamour and the you know the whole thing
and the people we saw we were at the
Catalina just a few nights ago and we
saw people I've known since I mean 40
years 40 years still coming out still
supporting you but online now we've got
another world okay you've got people
online right now who are talking about
the dresses the songs the earrings the
shoes it affected their lives that's
what impressed me and made me realize it
was a minor miracle you know to see
people who I know I have favorite songs
that like take me there you know I can
think of a song right okay there's a
summer please and go right back sandy
there's a song in everybody's life to
create that for other people ah that's a
good stop
yeah it's primo it really is but you
know you don't know to only expand
someone's awareness yeah that's another
one of these things that we write tear
so much about yes watch a piece of
content where someone just teaches you
something where you go whoa seeing the
world in this new
yeah I have to go share this with other
people maybe want to build something
with that yeah and so that is also said
this was so cool that you said this that
um Ray said that he would do what he
does for free yeah because when you do
what you love yes it doesn't feel like
work do you want to do it every single
day no matter what absolutely set up I'd
set up this equipment here any any time
I don't love interviewing people that
are 24 hours it's open its own and the
one thing that I'd say about that is I
think there's more research coming out
about the less a CEO or an entrepreneur
gets paid the harder they work yeah so
when they start making too much money
they start spending their money on more
things and losing sight of the vision
but also if you make money sometimes you
can put that into clear doing cool
things like maybe hiring editors or
hiring marketers distribution channels
so there's some sort of balance have
there yeah but I like I love that point
and you also you know you took us
through a an evolution of The Supremes
and and and also just how like having a
fan flying to Switzerland to see you
yeah that just that's so it really is
you know we went to England last year
and it was so cold it was what people
came out you know we had sold-out shows
all across and you see people these
songs affected people and you don't
realize when you write
how it's going to affect people you
don't it's a it's an obscure thing like
this [ __ ] like who's like how are you
how are your words get effective all the
[ __ ] yeah it's very secure yeah that's
right you're very careful with your
curation of your words just like you are
with your songs that's true
and I mean you know to have Stevie
Wonder say you know you're I mean Stevie
Wonder we're talking about Kevin say you
know you're one of the best lyricist
I've ever met
well you know I'm good but words are
important words are important they put
our thoughts into reality and
conversation you know it's it's a
conversation a love song there's nothing
like a love song an unconditional love
oddly enough I mean I wrote it with
Jeffrey chin Jeffrey had a track okay
he's my good friend from San Francisco
he's a tremendous pianist and arranger
he does a lot of film stuff he said I
got this track you know he said I don't
I don't really write like pop music you
know but I got this track and you you
need to hear this drag or not he played
it for me over the phone and this is
funny because all right with Stevie
Wonder over the phone too but he said
listen to I listen to it I went away I
got back to it it just came out you know
I wrote the melody and the lyrics and it
just something fits or it doesn't you
can just pick it out of the air it's
there already you know it is it's a
magical process and I played it and you
know there's a little fear involved
because when you you write something you
know that's his track like is he gonna
like that melody but you heard it you
know it's magic
it's it's magic it's good fun it's sexy
and it's it's one of those you know we
need more music you can dance with your
baby
all right no come on this is what you
were pointing at earlier okay what is
what is occurring in the music industry
right now why don't we see more
unconditional love style music we see
more violence don't we because if you're
talking about violence and young people
are listening and they get hard they
become hardened they they become a nerd
too you know they're afraid to be soft
do they're afraid to be tender you know
I mean there's it's ridiculous it's
absolutely ridiculous it has made for
that's where the truest humanity comes
that's right you know it's a very basic
thing tones the tones musical tones you
know you can hear and because I sing
high you know certain high tones
I can hear radio waves you know it's
really high and I find it just very
annoying but you know it's part of life
but it's only because my ear is strained
to that but my heart our heart is
trained to love absolutely I want to
tell you about beer oil calm one more
time
beer oil the e Royal dot-com beer oil
calm is a video site so on Facebook as
part of Facebook and there are almost
40,000 members and these are people who
come on there and make videos of
themselves of what's going on in their
lives
some of them are struggling some of them
are happy some of that like people are
and like people do but they talk about
what's going on in their own lives and
then other people come and support them
non-judgmental
there's not another place like this on
earth it was started by Bryant McGill
and Jenny young McGill his wife and they
wrote a book called simple reminders
simple reminders it's just little
aphorisms little things like think of
one of mine
write a good one listening listening is
the beginning of almost every human
contact listening little statements like
that that people can read every day
that's simple reminders and they decided
because brian has a billion literally a
billion followers it has more followers
than Oprah online you know and it's
because they touch the nerve of it we
live in a society where people judge you
all the time the Internet is anonymous
the great extent you can say what you
want you burn somebody down never know
who you are
we've lost human contact and it gets
worse
it gets worse and it will as it goes
along if it continues the same way they
call it social media but how social is
it you know you go on you would get
addicted to the what is it what is it
you get addicted to followers the
subscribers likes there you go the
vanity metrics the attention economy
that you're just your leader your
marketed to like a psychometric
profiling that's exactly right
and it's damaging to the human psyche
and people don't even realize it
so Brian and Jenny decided to start a
site where people could come and
inspire and uplift and support each
other there's no other place like that
on earth be royal calm the bio links in
the bio check it out royalty is manners
these manners and humanity exactly
exactly
it's a very loving thing and it has
brought people literally out of the
doldrums people who have been addicted
to drugs people who are loved made so
many and then just you know people who
just want to talk to people want to
share their lives they make a little
video two minutes long like talk for 15
minutes if you want yes but it's a
tremendous idea beyond mere oil calm
there are what it should be in life and
there are now finally more and more
communities developing out like this and
we're now starting to also leverage
machine learning to be able to see that
only you feel a certain way yeah there
are actually other people around you
that are actually communicating with you
on this thread that you can go and meet
with in person so you don't need to just
do it on flame so yes it brings us back
it does it brings us back to human to
human I so believe because you know
being human if you think about it we're
the only what should we call us species
who has that choice we are given choice
to do what we want to live the way we
want to live and to waste it to me
is a great crime it's a crime we are
stunted and stilted by people's limits
other people's
did other people the way other people
think about you but we have the ability
to override that I'm very much believing
that this year which i think is you know
hopefully will be a better year for all
of us you know the possibility is there
but in the ways that we haven't
considered the ways of joining together
the way of uplifting the way of helping
each other the way of supporting where
the inspiring of making people feel good
about themselves in building self-esteem
we have real problems on earth we're
gonna run out of water some places
they're already out of the water
that's as basic as it gets we can't live
without water
most of the entrepreneurs the scientists
thank God for the broad science Film
Festival yes you get to talk to people
who are in the scientific community are
thinking off world already well at the
edge of knowledge a solving the world's
problems there you go yeah and this is
so tell us about your passion for steam
advocacy yeah yeah well the thing is you
know I have always known that I was
going to do I have always painted song
written songs created in any way that's
possible and photography and almost
anything I've been willing to jump in
and try that but there are limits you
know there's the starving artist sinning
drone and I don't believe in that why
should you starve you should succeed if
you are talented and you work as hard as
you do but you have confidence in what
you do and know what you're doing the
thing about steam though I was very
happy to have been thrown in to a group
of people and it was through the Google
Lunar XPrize prizes incentivizing
innovation is
it really is we need to do more about
sourcing ideas yeah that's right it
raises the bar you know the the think
tank the mind group you know
intelligence the people I was I was an
advisor for Canada's team team plan B
and I was just enthralled because it was
a love story you know the debris on skis
husband and wife so intelligence so you
know science was their base but they
came out of Ukraine and they went to
Canada and they got involved with this
prize and it was a family effort and
that just you know that warmed my heart
so they between rooting for them talking
back and forth to them I met some other
lovely people asam I don't know if you
know asam asam chicagee
and foreign as they both were involved
yes they both were involved with our
science and that's how I met Carrie you
know but I've always loved science
I loved chemistry I loved biology I
loved mathematics I love all of the
things that you know I I wasn't allowed
to do because I grew up at a time when a
girl did certain girl things and boys
were encouraged to do science and math
and you see but I had this desire and I
would read I'd read I'd go to the
library that's how I spent my Saturdays
growing up in New York in the main
library there I'd get chemistry books
and read them you know what I like
fascinated in a gemology and just I mean
just so many things
earth science this was thrilling to me
and then to come along and find that
this is a thing stem and steam and
Carrie Carrie kook Rose is Georgie
yes you know a ballet dancer who
suddenly said ok and I'm a good ballet
dance
say yes but I could be an engineer it's
good stop and what an example for other
young women you know yeah we've talked
Katie she and Assam and foreign hands
and I talked about the world and what's
possible for girls the most thrilling
thing last year was the Afghan girls
robotics - no they built their robot
from household goods I mean you can't
get any better talk about inspiring and
then the one young lady whose father was
killed because they did that that's a
serious as it gets and yet because they
went forward because they embraced it
and dug in there are schools being built
now for girls science schools and then
to see for Kari to say okay we've got
science over here we've got art over
here
mind meld you know it it's just it's
perfect
yeah to me it is a perfect situation
really is there's a there's a certain
equality of opportunity and an equal
economic degrees of freedom that need to
be raised across the planet for all
people as soon as possible like a
baseline of socio economics and degrees
of freedom they give people those basic
needs and ways to actualize themselves
and so stem and steam is one of those
things that enables us to raise that
baseline up and then it gives us the
tools we need to do things like become
an interplanetary salt aging go through
all these extremely exciting yeah
challenges now okay
a couple quick questions on the way out
okay couple quick questions are what
would you say is a driving core
principle of yours of mine yeah kindness
kindness because I think more than
anything other than maybe truth when you
are kind to people it's like a healing
once again anything that's gone wrong in
our world can be healed by kindness and
that principle carries me up lifts me
enough to make me be happy and grateful
to people I'm grateful for what is
coming and that's what makes it come you
know but kindness if I was remembered by
one thing I would want it to be that
that people thought oh she's kind this
it was kind to me it doesn't you know
you can give gifts you can give money
you can give opportunities but your time
you can't get time back if you give your
time to people who I know you know why
not help someone why not why not uplift
someone we have that capacity yeah we
have the brainpower to think about that
and the other thing I would have to say
would be peace because I'm a great great
advocate for peace I'm the National
Director for film music in the arts for
the Peace Prize foundation
and I'm we're just getting ready really
to jump off and do some tremendous
things because peace is not just about
saying no war if each of us had an
individual piece you like to read and
are you peaceful while you're reading oh
yeah when you're painting peaceful as
can be when you create anything love
peaceful you know it's a great great
concept and it's just so broad I love
that I love I love kindness and I just
leave a wake behind you everywhere you
go you bring it with you and then it
just butterflies effect there's things
in people that's so true another
question on the way out is this wouldn't
be simulation if we didn't ask you are
we in a simulation I don't know it's
very matrix see the thing about it is
you know if we if this is not our real
our reality it's pretty good you know I
kind of like it and I kind of can get
used to it sure I would say it probably
is a simulation in a certain way sure
but I like that concept like an Emily
you're you're you've uh you've leveled
up your attribute of singing in
songwriting to max I like it and there's
always room to keep to keep growing
absolutely okay and last question what
do you thinks the most beautiful thing
in the world I can't tell you
it's just oh it has very much
I'd have to say to love you know there's
nothing like being in love it's real
special you know it is I recommend it
highly
I don't necessarily recommend marriage
because everybody can't handle marriage
you know it takes some commitment and
some other stuff some consideration you
know and a whole lot of kindness
understanding and all of that but I
definitely love you know it's just those
glorious thing it is and I it's my right
love song better than that when I say
you know there's so many words you know
but it's it's engendering
a tenderness and finding that in another
person you know and it's infinite isn't
it yes a lot and I think if people
realize that there'd be a lot happier
place is mine yeah place is all mine
thank you so much it's my pleasure
yeah my joy you're such a wealth of
wisdom we have to have you back
yeah when studio NSF's always open to
you we'll let you know about you yeah
this has been such an honor and a
pleasure say in the song all you gotta
do is call and there's so much
unconditional love for you all thank you
so much for tuning in and we greatly
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know what you've been thinking check
out the links below be royal calm yeah
also what is another good link well you
can find me online on Twitter at Hsu say
s us a ye I'm on facebook I'm on
Instagram Instagram is kind of new to me
but I get
it's kind of wild you know it is so we
got all those links below so and check
them out
yeah um keep supporting great artists
and entrepreneurs that you highly want
to increase their impact on the world so
go and continue supporting them
supporting us so we can keep doing cool
things like this and lastly go and build
the future everyone go and manifest your
destiny into the world we love you so
much
and we'll see you soon for real that's a
that's a wrap thank you so much thank
you you're wonderful you are wondering